oggi incrementa cry posso fare la carica
c'è tutto quello che ti pare che fa caso
bastardo
dai dai
ciao ragazzi benvenuti erano puntata di
vita ha buttata oggi mi faccio un tè
insieme ad alice venturi ciao ciao a
tutti quanti so che sei un momento in un
percorso psicologico
ecologico di body transformation diete e
compagnia bella però siccome siamo molto
amici come sono venuto a roma fi come
regola perfetto ma cosa mi fai da bere
un long and leeds che jls richiede
tequila analcolica bocca analcolica che
per niente acqua altre due tipi da qui
diverse come che sono tutte acque queste
gene analcolico analcolico quindi manca
la la coca le quantità sono facilissime
1233 perché cambia a botte perché il rum
e 23 room.it re modica
il gene e proprio tipico di semplice lo
versi con mangia ma
qualsiasi dosi e va bene sia come
alice io o meglio quando avevo 16 anni
andavano in discoteca qualcuno mi
offriva da bere io dal mio sangue questo
sì che ti fa sballare
ecco qua guglielmo matto stessi che la
coca serramenti certo ma gliele voto
dopo se lo aggiudicò la coca collaro
loro linea era giovane questa cosa
commentando il cervello perché barmal
aggiungono e sai perchè perchè possiamo
far vedere la prima clip di un mio
cocktail
a una zolletta prandin 6 grazie
a di sbocco
pubbliche avanti grazie siamo pronti per
una nuova puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
ma dai ad un core ciniero ciao quando
aveva 16 anni ho dovuto fare un esame
per cambiare il liceo problema che era
appena tornato da una vacanza all'estero
in cui ne ripresa un brutto virus
intestinale ebbe mezzo dell'esame
scritto puntato spruzzo non solo sul
banco ma anche sull'auto che stessa
lei da zero ma così non so se
raccontarti da questa allora non rido
perché sono stata veramente male quel
ristorante era un mio ristorante del
cuore ok cielo sembra non avevo mangiato
sempre benissimo quel giorno mi sono
mangiata la grigliata di pesce molto in
macchina nella mia vita non mi sono mai
sentita così male in così poco tempo ero
a metà strada cioè non poter ritornare
o durc e molla la macchina poi erano
sulla tangenziale
malissimo ma ma le figure tanto che mi
sono dovuto pulire con giacchetto che
poi ho abbandonato lì che rubare a tutti
i rendiconti un padre io ho fatto
partito shuttle in mezzo al magari dello
shuttle era un ombrello e poi la
macchina
una seppia
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
era veramente oltretutto tormento di
pelle che cacchio asciuga non ci batte
per niente te l'assicuro
una volta vado a casa di un ragazzo che
avevo appena conosciuto dai linea made
in c divertiamo un sacco parliamo
chiacchiere chiacchiere nulla di prima
che pensate male è ragazzi a casa noi
che stavamo lì a facebook no mettiamo i
puntini sulle i ok se io vengo a casa
tua si ragazzo
la prima sera dove ci siamo conosciuti
praticamente e perché devono scattare
bouquet i che sia chiaro cioè non mi fa
salire a casa tua le famiglie idea
collezione del rafale chissà ancora
collezioni che per fascia e fumanti così
si salvo a casa tua in questo caso
invece no strappo alla regola chissà
come conoscere una persona dopo un po è
un dovere a parlare per ore a parlare 4
a piacevoli una certa io guardavo un
secondo in bagno fiondo veramente la
lampada di seletti nel pattern è potuto
stavo lì e premi e premi e pre l'acqua
almeno arriva
così una carezza
ok per usarlo baci tanto guardo ovunque
ragazzi guardo un concetto punto cestino
del bagno ma cestino era di vimini ma
dentro c'era un sacco
vado sotto la doccia inizia a riempirlo
in quel momento mi rendo conto e ci sono
dei buchi quindi questi buchi cominciano
a schizzare ovunque medico devo far ciò
devo farcela vado verso correndo verso
il bagno giro ea quel punto lancio la
gavettonata che finalmente la banda
scarica ce l'ha capito che jack via nei
fondali dell'oceano ti auguriamo ospiti
allora per la serie spiega e posizioni
assurde giorno della mia maturità hanno
il solo capitol giorno del mio
compleanno ma al momento del mio turno
appunto questo sostenere l'esame andò a
fuoco la sterpaglia che si trovava fuori
la scuola dovrebbe evacuare l'edificio
per qualche ora dopo il centro ma torna
in aula sostenendo l'esame con su nulla
fosse successo l'avvenimento era uno il
suo compleanno giusto due la maturità
tra il fuoco di soppresso il compleanno
la giacca no
il mio esame di maturità si sa per cose
che mi hanno colpito la prima una mia
insegnante che mi chiede non mi ricordo
chi se fosse un poeta romantico
illuminista non mi ricordo come era io
sbaglio o 3 2 un altra roba su le onde
elettromagnetiche dove io per spiegarlo
incominciare a certo punto a fare una
roba così a intende un professore perché
non sapesse ragazzi che questo è
fondamentale in un elettro magnetico
viaggiano sullo stesso asse una va così
e l'altra sullo stesso perché sono sia
elettriche magnetiche quindi va beh il
problema l'ho spiegato anche a mio
professore così e quindi lui stava lì un
po anche in imbarazzo per me dice
omosessuale per infusione
in che cosa che è successo
alzati scusami scusatevi vi mette un
attimo qua e faccio un attimino inganno
un attimo il mio mio caso perché mi ha
detto che
dice un'altra cosa che mi è rimasta
impressa è di inglese letterature
inglesi non sapevo niente vedi ce l'hai
fatta
tra venti minuti lo devo rifare è finita
è finita inglese non avevo preparato
nulla
chiedo una sola cosa senti dimmi una
cosa di letteratura inglese non è mica
me le dice mi siedo e quelli mi fanno
una domanda su quella cosa figurone io
capire una cosa importante ragazzi una
cosa insieme dovremo capire tutti quanti
che in realtà nella vita non va avanti
il talentuoso non va avanti con me
studia mi vanno avanti i collusi i
ricattatori e coloro con la faccia da
culo io quel giorno mi ritrovai due nati
che al posto dell'inno
fatto interno perché sono una persona
educata poi la giacca non l'ha fatto
interno va bene cosi guglielmo tutti
ritiene un mio amico che
studio fatto la tesi e linguistico
equa ragazze si conclude la mia amicizia
con voi e non hai fatto il classico
linguistico ritrova lo scientifico ha
fatto ragazzi quasi conclude per
ottenere hai studiato un giorno della
tua vita ne facevamo 52 ore settimanali
con credo cioè però greta esame decreta
anche il caso facevate voi intanto è la
creta la creatività la creta o qaeda la
crepa so fare soffrire una katana ok lo
so io avevamo ceramica fabbro fabbro ma
fabrio nel senso che vedi uscivate
almeno a duplicare chiavi di casa o no
sobrio per le armature per le armature
ragazze pulite ma anche fatto il
artistico di torino in ospiti non sta
facendo
una pubblicità appello attenzione amici
dell'artistico aspettate voi lo sapete
che noi siamo sempre devi grati per la
nostra scelta però la realtà è che noi
siamo felici della nostra scelta perché
noi ci siamo alzati per cinque anni la
nostra vita felici di andare a quella
scuola perché ti divertivi quindi credo
che mentre noi portavamo il dizionario
di greco antico estate con scatolone
fabbricone losco io stavo a forgia al
ferro
allora per i tre anni successivi alla
maturità to iniziava preparare la roba
che avresti portato alla maturità perché
non era solo la tesina ma erano delle
robe anche pratiche la creta la devi
plasmare si deve seccare la devi cuocere
la devi lasciare raffreddare la devi
colorare con le con le pitture
percentuali e cuocere cioè e progettare
ovviamente per noi cercavamo tutto
perché l'indirizzo design
io avevo preparato una roba bellissima
ragazzi per far sempre in casa c'era una
ciotola
insalatiera ispirata ad un quadro di chi
the ring aspetta visto per così è
esattamente il quadro di the ring te lo
giuro ti manderò la reference
imbarazza è impressionante cioè io lo
vedo così una cacata e keith haring ha
fatto un quadro che era così identico
stack agata vergognati vogliamo quando
verrà in uscita da casa mia ti giuro che
ti faccio mangiare in quella sorta ma
con quanto sia uscita 96 fatte quei
quattro di quante merkel ha pagata
benissimo io arrivo alla mia maturità
allora le arrivò con la mia tesina che
ovviamente i nostri desiderosa i no sono
grosse così
no perché il castello questo mondo tutti
gli oggetti erano su un tavolo a
sinistra ovviamente sono arrivata io
venturi la presenza a prendere l'oggetto
arriva con l'oggetto inciampa
inciampa inciampa e fa cadere a terra la
roma di mille pezzi prima del mio orale
io sono scoppiata a piangere per offesa
come non so cosa in più era pure
l'insegnante progettazione ammanco era
velo di filosofia che non capisce un ca
riesce se venuta qui a deprimermi
possiamo giocare ecco facciamo una cosa
divertente il gioco abbiamo creato è
alice è veramente una noiosissima e
rompi sotuttoio del
allora alice abbiamo una lavagna della
roba e lavinia pronta a spiegarci che
cosa andremo a fare a turno ognuno dei
giocatori scegli una categoria il gioco
era staffetta come dire per nota
qualora uno dei due giocatori ritel iss
invalida la risposta dell'avversario
attenzione siete anche giudici oppure si
rendesse conto che lo stesso ha usato
una risposta jar data dovrà premere il
tasto rosso io inizierei con un
bellissimo disney valgono solo i
classici disney nella lista ufficiale
fornita da wikipedia
aristogatti all'anima cenerentola la
sirenetta biancaneve la bella e la
bestia dumbo le prime imperatore no
no non è nei classici ai disabili e le
precedenti dei materassi sono malaccio
le follie dell'imperatore però non può
esserne classi dei [ __ ] come te il
titolo di quest'oggi questo spaccato
ora sceso io le mie preferite parole in
francese ai
tutte quelle previste dal vocabolario
legge e scandire via vitt
che
male c'è
ma che cazzo stai
cioccolata
cazzo tutto si
è visto solo una frase in francese
ovvero registro in cui sia un mito jong
un e book and museum e allora chi l'ha
fatta tutta cioè io la canzone cantavo
porterà
dai proviamo
pop music
carta antipop gli sfidanti dovranno
cantare il nome dell'artista pop sesto
tiziano ma visto che si è visto il
commento e fai tiziano ferro cioè hai
detto tu che ami sta rubando il tempo
questa
che col culo mio tiziano
frutta ai party il tiziano ferro
e premi però
madonna
lady gaga testing michael jackson l'anno
bambini peccato enrique iglesias ma con
il ira man e mamma pure bello la cantata
matteo romano
ultimo va benissimo
giorgia
shakira shakira a nord abito
altre parole secondo s sumed airtel
parola 24 lettere come da titolo pagano
solo le parole e non le onomatopee sole
more more mori moro mare mario il pane
pane ben bene appena 8 oro no porto
[Applauso]
credo che ora
anche un'altra due 3 a 1 e posso fare
solo harry potter il superhero faccio
fregare malissimo partito dominare tutta
un personaggio di brillantina il film
dei libri mirtilla malcontenta r cedric
ron hermione luna
olimpica al bus norberto ciò ginetto
pixie da
34 a great gran bastardo drago
professore flitwick vostri memorie
completo nevi
l'artista malfoy lucius malfoy
professoressa sprite dov'è
olivander
l'italiano l'inglese
libri possiamo riassumere in due secondi
per tutti quelli che ci stanno seguendo
alice è effettivamente uno soprattutto i
[ __ ]
sì ma guglielmo peggio force causa
ospiti fondamentalmente mentre
parcheggio la macchina davanti al bar
dove avevano appuntamento stavo dentro
una ragazza prendo un mattone in sfonda
il vetro passeggiato della macchina
perché vede una giacca da donna molto
appariscente settentrione ad una mia
amica e la ragazza si è giustificata
dicendo che la macchina è identica e
cioè la stessa marcatura della macchina
del suo ragazzo che abitava nel palazzo
di sopra e niente fondamentalmente le
isole incassata dal professore fa
appunto parte grande traditore
una mia rimborsato il ovviamente ma qui
ma questa è pazza non ce la può fare
basta qui siamo nell'iperuranio
amicizia quante macchine possono avere
la stessa marcatura essere lo stesso
modello sotto casa o di un botto come
marte in
almeno due vista la situazione almeno
due quindi dico allora timo ha
rimborsato
ma che c'entra ma sei matta in culo e se
invece fosse stata la macchina vera
avrei chiesto come mai c'era un cappotto
molto esoso nelle nei nemesi di lì
posteriori poi se mi accorgo e mi dice
la caccia val di spacco il finestrino ma
prima te lo chiedo che dice ti posso
dire una cosa ma questo cappotto r di
pelle guarda secondo me ha detto molto
appariscente alla poco forse poteva
essere ma scusa ma secondo te e lui l'ha
vista a spaccare il finestrino e detto
stavo letto
bastardo
ascoltiamo un ultimo messaggio e poi
andiamo tutti a dormire
lascia fare una delle cose più
divertenti che insieme ai capitato è
stata mediazioni che il paper
sull'altare e niente nel mezzo della
preghiera dei fedeli sono caduta per
terra rifaccia stupendo traumatizzata
vita tutti cioè nel bel mezzo c'è la
preghiera è da fermi
ragazze svenuta
studi così tutta la tua vita d'ufficio e
se tu vai al cinema al cinema a teatro
cosa fai dai dai ascoltami nessuno
guarda vedi ce l'hai fatta ma è
questione di un secondo non è che noi a
nessuno se mi metto a far due passi
ragazzi io che dire se vuoi nei terzini
questa puntata
tu sei sicura di bene
[Musica]
io posso fare se fare vai dai dai bravo
bravo dai ragazzi siamo arrivati ai fini
questa puntata ali grazie unite per
essere stata mia ospite reiko prego per
i miei racconti
le persone ti guarderanno con un altro
anch'io vi diranno di started ero in
macchina che dire ragazzi noi a questo
punto ci vedremo sempre qui ma non so
quando ciao
quando si sia secondo caso mi pare che
questo form mi sono personali per meglio
devo chiedere permesso e perdono alla
gente vai calma che siamo finiti mirati
già incalzano nessuno e che questo posto
è mio ecco la mia
e tutto finisce
da svezzare la decisione fino allora a
posto così
[Musica]